all of his Shenanigans is going to be
far more damaging
to the kids one day then my tape will
ever be Kim Kardashian calling it like
she sees it on the season premiere of
the Kardashians even through all of the
craziness of everything that Kanye says
about us we stay silent we stay silent
well she's not staying silent anymore
people don't see the context behind it
let's rewind back in September Kanye
West publicly slammed his ex and former
mother-in-law Kris Jenner on social
media sharing screenshots of text
messages seemingly with Kim vowing the
two daughters they share nine-year-old
North and five-year-old Chicago will
never pose for Playboy and will never
have a sex tape like Kim I think I can
handle anything I just get really
heartbroken from my mom posing for
Playboy was actually a way for Kim to
reclaim her power they really really
really really really really want to do
it ever since the sex tape scandal
Kim filmed with her then boyfriend Ray J
leaked online
Kim you're doing amazing
look so down on me for like my tape and
brings it up
all over town and I have to sit here and
not say anything ever
because I know one day my kids will
appreciate that along with North and shy
Kim and Kanye have two sons
seven-year-olds saying to Aunt
four-year-old Saul they share custody of
all four after their divorce was
finalized in November more than a year
after Kim filed to end the marriage it's
hard
it was like co-parenting it's really
[__] hard Kim kept a lot of their
issues private over the years including
Kanye's apparent fixation on her
supposedly having an affair with Drake
speculation that only intensified after
the rapper dropped his track in my
feelings featuring lyrics about a girl
named Kiki Kim's nickname
he was the one that started a rumor
that said I was having hooking up with
Drake so the person that's supposed to
protect me the most
publicly would accuse me of having an
affair and for the record Kiki is
apparently Keisha Shantae an actual ex
of Drake's this is my first girlfriend I
ever had in my life
[Applause]
a real legend somebody I love with all
my heart piece of Shantae as for Kim
following her split from Kanye she dated
Pete Davidson he's just super genuine
the two called it quits back in August
after nine months of dating there was
like a lot of guilt I he went through a
lot because
you know my relationship but during
their time together Kanye took several
shots at Pete on social media and even
name checked the Saturday Night Live
alum in his track easy God sent me from
that crash just so I could be Pete Davis
but now Kim says she's not giving up on
love I go back and forth in my feelings
sometimes like oh who's ever going to
want to date me who's going to want to
deal with the drums but my person will
be like
call that like it's gonna be hard but
we're together and like we're gonna do
this so I'm just waiting for that person
[Music]